unfortunately we cannot commit to  concrete timelines at this point  and that's why the state so far has re  has refrained from using any dates  well during today's covet call with  health and state officials they  expressed frustration due to some  challenges they face when it comes to  distribution because of what they are  receiving from the federal government  they claim it's hard to predict  timelines because shipments  of the vaccines are delivered  differently each week and sometimes it's  not what they ordered  they also said christmas and new year's  data is still coming in  again they are asking for patience from  the public